today we're going to look at the ponds
we're going to see the importance of the
ponds and then talk about how you should
think about playing your ponds during
the game so first we're going to talk
about how much the ponds are worth each
piece and chest has a measurement of how
important they are the ponds are where
everything is based on points or ponds
so a pond is worth as you can imagine
one pond or one point depending on how
someone's talking about it at the
beginning they are the weakest piece on
the board but later on in the game they
can become very valuable they can
promote which will give into later
meaning that if they reach the other
side of the board the last rank they can
turn into any piece they want they can
turn into a queen they can turn into a
bishop but not a rogue the only piece
they can't turn into it's just you can
imagine the king they can't turn into a
king but there's two goals at the
beginning of a game when you move your
pawns you should have two goals in mind
you should move your pawns to gain
center control and the second is you
should have King safety so you want to
keep the pawns in front of the King to
have King safety now let's get into the
movement the movement of the pawns is on
the very first and only the first move
that they make they can move one or they
can move two squares once they move so
if I move two III on my first move my
next move i can't move two spaces I can
only move one space forward and if I
move two spaces it doesn't matter my
next move can only be one space forward
if I move any pawn it can only move
forward one space but
on the very first move of the pawn it
can be two spaces for it it can be two
or wanted depends on how you want also
know that the pawn is the only piece
that cannot move backwards so all your
other pieces can move forward backward
side to side does matter the pawn can
only move forward so always keep that in
mind so you don't want to overextend
your pawns in certain situations because
they can't come back and you can have a
lot of space between your pawns and your
pieces and a lot of times it's very hard
to defend all your pawns in that
situation so let's go ahead and talk
about how it captures the pawn is the
only piece that captures differently the
how it moves the pawn moves forward only
forward but it captures diagonally so
let's say black black pawn is right here
we capture diagonally right here if
there was a black pawn on d5 our white
pawn actually can't move there's no
piece for it to capture on c5 or a five
which are the only possible capturing
squares and he can't capture forward
so in this say in this position our pawn
on d4 has zero moves now let's say we
move our pawn to e4 this black pawn he
can't there's no piece for him to
capture on 'if on scuse me on c4 he
can't capture on d4 he can only but he
can capture on e4 because he can
remember he can capture diagonally so
that is how the pawn captures now
there's one other way that a pawn can
capture that I'm going to go over right
now and that is on Posada and that is if
you have a pawn on the fifth rank and it
would be the fourth rank it for black
what you can do is if your opponent only
it if you're on the fifth rank if your
opponent moves two spaces and it has to
be two spaces then on your next turn and
only on your next turn you can capture
called on passant
and you can actually move from here and
capture this pawn you actually don't end
up on the square that you capture the
pawn now let's say black moved his pawn
to c5 and you moved your knight and then
let's say black moved his knight to f6
you can no longer capture on c6 you only
have that one turn to do it and also
keep in mind let's say the black pawn
was on e6 and you move up and black
moves his pawn to e5 he only moved it up
once so in this case you cannot capture
this pawn the only time you can capture
is if he moves up two spaces his very
first move and you're on the fifth rank
only on your next turn can you move to
c6 and it could be depending on where it
is but you would basically move one
space behind it you're still capturing
diagonally but you're not ending up on
the square that the pawn was so that is
how a pawn captures now the last thing I
want to go over is what you can do to
promote and promote basically means that
you have your pawn on
and he moves to the last square so let's
take a look at it if let's say we have
our pawn on c7 if he can get to c8 he
can turn into any piece you want so if
you want to get another Queen that's
completely fine if you want to move and
you want to get a knight you can which
is very valuable later in the game it
you could have a king and a pond verse
the King and it may look like it's
completely hopeless but if you promote
your pawn to a queen well now you have a
queen and a king versa King you're going
to have a very easy win so early on you
want your pawns to have center control
and you want them to protect your king
later on in the game you want them
obviously to support your pieces but you
also want to if you can promote your
pawns so they can become more powerful
pieces so this is how the pawn works
hopefully this is helped in your game
and you can use this in the future